je suis à la tête d'un groupe
parlementaire excusez-moi du peu où il y
a des anciens socialistes des
sociaux-démocrates jusqu'aux UDA en
passant par des Outre-mer on y dit vous
êtes un groupe hétéroclite mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
on est un groupe qui sait dialoguer
discuter on a la clé de la réussite la
clé de la réussite c'est le dialogue
entre nous pourquoi est-ce que nous
faisons entre nous nous pourrions pas le
faire
de la République
arrive au groupe les autres donc faites
le plus largement ressembler
ce qui est important c'est pas un
président de la République avec une
cervelle puissance 10 c'est un président
de la République avec des grandes
oreilles pour écouter c'est pas la
taille du cerveau qui compte c'est la
taille des oreilles
alors ma conscient de public c'est na
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir
Tam traduis bonsoir et vous aviez donc
une question sur la proposition de loi
du groupe liotte sur les retraites à
Bertrand pencher et oui tous les yeux
sont focalisés bien sûr sur le 8 juin
date à laquelle votre proposition de loi
doit être examinée d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous avez un doute sur le fait qu'elle
le soit bien le 8 juin
a toujours des doutes ce qui est
important c'est que les parlementaires
qui sont contre cette loi se mobilisent
après chacun agira en responsabilité
il y a une manifestation importante le
si le 6 juin
on ne sait jamais je rappelle quand même
que notre mot de la motion de censure
failli passer à nevoi près on sait pas
ce résultat là vrai dire bon ça veut
dire que il manque encore 9 comme on ne
voit pour pour changer la donne en
matière de retraite bon la notion de
censure les abstentionnistes se prononce
pas je pense que certains
que la majorité soit en train de d'agir
justement pour faire en sorte que votre
texte ne soit pas débattu vous avez
signé un courrier aujourd'hui vous
interpellez sur vos inquiétudes sur le
fait que certains manœuvres veulent
parler de 10 recevabilité financière
autour de votre texte oui parce que si
pour ne pas passer un texte de loi on
s'en prend au fondements démocratique
c'est-à-dire un parlement qui est en
incapacité de légiférer je peux vous
dire qu'on allume le bâton de dynamite
et je pense que ça sera encore pire de
ne pas voter que pour le gouvernement et
la majoritaire relative se faire
renvoyer un texte sous la majorité des
paramètres sont contre donc je il y a
une verte si on ne va pas jusqu'au
jusqu'à l'examen du texte c'est un bâton
de dynamique
pour la démocratie vous rendez compte
mais les recevabilité elle peut pas être
soulevée dans le cas de cette réforme
des retraites quand le président dit ça
coûte 15 milliards
il y a jamais eu aucune proposition de
loi par des des propositions de loi des
projets de loi des professions de loi
venant des parlementaires on leur a
jamais demandé de faire accompagner tout
ça par des recettes par des recettes
équivalentes 1 ça s'est jamais fait dans
notre histoire donc est-ce qu'on veut
changer
est-ce qu'on veut changer est-ce qu'on
veut changer les règles en cours de
route c'est quand même très grave on
n'est pas dans un une démocratie
bananière quoi bananière démocratie
ils invoquaient l'article 40 sur votre
proposition de loi évidemment on va pas
marcher en permanence et bricoler
bricoler notre commande notre
fonctionnement donc moi ça me paraît ça
me paraît invraisemblable que ce cas est
deuxièmement deuxièmement qu'est-ce
qu'on dit à travers cette proposition de
loi nous prenons nos responsabilités 1
on revient sur cette augmentation de
l'âge légal de la départ à la retraite
parce que c'est injuste je suis allé
faire mes courses chez la semaine
dernière la caissière me dit écoutez 67
ans ils sont fous
et elle marchera peut-être plus tôt
aussi la caissière elle a peut-être
commencé plutôt et elle partirait
peut-être plutôt
la cour elle n'est pas je vais ensuite
le lendemain acheter des plats préparés
chez mon boucher qui me dit je dois
partir en septembre je sais pas quand je
vais partir et je discute avec la
responsable de la Carsat qui me dit ça
fait 20 ans que je travaille à la Carsat
la caisse de retraite j'ai jamais vu une
réforme aussi précipitée de l'opposition
des Français mais si on en revient à
l'Assemblée nationale pour l'instant le
texte a été déclaré recevable par le
Bureau de l'Assemblée qu'est-ce qui peut
se passer qu'est-ce que vous craignez
qu'il se passe au niveau de la de la
majorité pour qu'il puisse essayer de
déclarer le texte qui recevable
on peut on peut tout imaginer avec eux
vous avez il nous avait promis juré
craché parole de scout qu'on allait pas
avoir utilisé 49-3 ils ont tué le 49-3
bon euh
des tas d'amendements il peut y avoir de
l'obstruction parlementaire de la
parlotte comment de la parlotte à tous
les nids de la parole tu as tous les
niveaux donc je pense vraiment que
il est vraiment indispensable qui est
pas d'obstruction parlementaire parce
que je pense que le remède serait pire
que le mal
alors je voudrais vous faire réagir à ce
qu'a dit la première ministre la semaine
dernière elle a dit c'est assez
irresponsable de leur part elle part
elle parle de vous de laisser croire que
leur démarche permettra de revenir sur
la réforme des retraites cette
proposition de loi est une façon
d'attirer la lumière en disant pas la
vérité aux Français qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez et est-ce que vous mentez
aux Français en leur laissant croire que
votre texte pourrait réellement abroger
la réforme des retraites moi je pense
que le gouvernement le président de la
République et la majorité relative ils
sont dans une peur panique et qu'ils
utilisent tous les arguments pour
effrayer les uns et les autres et nous
décrédibiliser est-ce qu'il est
irresponsable que le Parlement se
prononce on élu au suffrage universel
direct si les représentants du peuple ne
peuvent pas se prononcer dans quel pays
dans quelle démocratie sommes-nous
politique dans un coup médiatique avec
cette proposition de loi mais pourquoi
un coup médiatique un coup politique si
nous nous si une majorité de députés se
prononce contre
système de réforme des retraites tel
qu'il a
démocratique de la réforme des retraites
il a déjà eu lieu Bertrand pencher il
est terminé ce cheminement démocratique
il est terminé comment on a est-ce qu'un
moment on a discuté de cet article 7
devenu article 10 de la con de sur
l'augmentation de l'âge légal de départ
c'est quand même c'est quand même fort
de café que les députés se que les
députés se fanent se prononcent pas et
moi je pense que si les députés se
prononcent ça sera un séisme politique
et je pense que ça aidera d'ailleurs le
président Macron à sortir de cette crise
sociale et politique voyez qui peut plus
sortir sans être camouflé avec vous
voulez l'aider en fait à sortir de la
crise démocratique
gouverner le pays c'est quatre
prochaines années intelligemment en se
disant que je me suis trompé il y a pas
on peut aussi des erreurs je me suis
trompé on va pas passer en force on va
l'aider à trouver des solutions et que
vous allez voir que pendant quatre ans
on va bien travailler pour notre pays
alors au fond est-ce que vous pensez
qu'elle peut être votée cette
proposition de loi oui c'est-à-dire que
tous vos alliés qui ont été consignés
donc qui ont consigné la nuque par
exemple vous pensez que vous ferez le
plein de voix à gauche de l'extrême
droite jusqu'à
les filles je pense que des parents
les
parlementaires républicains il y en
avait il y en a 19 qui ont voté la
motion de censure quand même un acte
fort j'imagine pas que les
parlementaires qui ont voté l'émotion de
censure ne viennent pas rejeter cette
cette
propositions
qui sont pas déplacés qui m'ont dit bah
si on avait su on l'aurait fait bon on
me dit qu'il y aurait à peu près 25
parlementaires LR contre cette réforme
il y en a beaucoup qui vont s'abstenir
bon vous rajoutez tout ça donc je pense
que ça va passer je pense que c'est pas
certain mais ça va passer mais je pense
que vraiment d'abord si nous votons ça
sera la revanche au moins de la
démocratie on pourra regarder nos
électeurs les yeux dans les yeux en leur
disant vous avez vous avez désigné à
l'Assemblée nationale on a tout fait
pour faire passer ce texte on est dans
une démocratie il faut que la démocratie
puisse s'exercer